hello everybody and welcome again to a
new presentation of a competition that
we have recently published
this time we are selecting
highly
qualified professionals in the field of
space and
defense i say highly quite qualified
professionals because indeed we offer
these competitions on quite advanced
levels
grade 87 and 9
in both the fields of defense industry
and space
you can apply for only one field and one
grade
now if you apply for the 89 grade which
is the highest grade
and
if the selection board things that you
do not qualify for the 89 grade
they can reassign you to the 87 grade
if you are okay with that so you can
indicate in your application form where
you
allow the selection board to do so
if you wish so
we have published on our website as
usual an infographic this one that you
see here which gives you in the blink of
an eye an overview of this competition
the eligibility criteria the different
steps of the competition and then
eventually the number of people that
we're looking to select this time
what i'll do in this presentation is
walk you through these different steps
with a bit of more detail to it
so first of all the eligibility criteria
for an ad7 competition you need at least
either a master degree plus six years of
experience in the field
or a bachelor degree with seven years of
experience
for 89 you need a master plus 10 years
or a bachelor degree plus 11 years of
experience
his experience must be of course in the
field the field of defense or space as
explained below there a couple of
examples defense includes defense
research and development procurement
defense
industrial policy
and then for the space domain you see
for instance space r d
economics law satellite navigation these
kind of things
then there's also of course a language
criterium
you need to speak at least two eu
languages
one of which must be english as you can
see below
one language you must master on level c1
so you need a thorough
language knowledge there
and your second language must be at
least level b2 meaning a satisfactory
level okay
how does the selection procedure look
like this there's always different steps
everything starts of course with an
application and a registration on our
website
a first selection is done through what
we call a talent screener i will explain
in a minute what that means the ones
getting through this first stage are
invited to the second stage which is an
assessment center and there we test a
set of skills and competencies
if you are successful you are what we
call a laureate and you can be recruited
by mainly
the commission director general for
defense industry and space we call it dg
defes
all right
so let's
dive into
the detail of these different steps
to apply you first of all need an epso
account
if you do not have an exo account yet
you can create one easily on our website
if you do have one do not create a
second one because you can only have one
account
to
take part in any competition that you
want
you have to apply on our website on the
home page
www.eu
careers.eu you will find a direct link
to this competition
you can apply in any of the 24 languages
apart from the talent screener part that
part you have to fill in english
you have to validate your application at
the latest on the 19th of july that's a
deadline for this competition
so by that date you can go in and out of
your application you know save it go
back complete it a bit more go back when
you want
but you have to validate it at the
latest on the 19th of july
once that is done we start selecting and
the first stage is this typical
talent screener phase which is basically
a set of
six to nine questions that you have to
answer when you fill out your
application
and we basically
um assess your qualifications here we
see we look at the degrees you have we
look at the professional experience you
have in these domains
and we give you scores for the answers
to these different questions
the candidates with the highest scores
are then invited to the second stage
which is the assessment center
in the assessment center i said we will
assess a number of skills and
competencies
firstly we test your reasoning skills we
test your verbal numerical and abstract
reading skills
in which language well not in english
but in the other language that you have
mentioned to us when you applied
you need a combined pass mark of 20 out
of 40 combined so meaning in theory you
can't fail for
one of these reasoning skills tests if
you if you want as long as you make up
for them uh in the other tests
i advise you strongly to
train this you can do so by checking out
our sample tests on the website
because first of all there is the level
of difficulty of these questions
but secondly there is also a time factor
involved
so you have to be able to solve these
questions under time pressure and by
training this you get better at this so
have a look on our sample tests to train
you for this phase
once you pass this phase once you have
the pass mark out of 20 out of 14
minimum you go to the next phase
when you go to the next phase you start
from zero again so the score you get
here in this reading skills test does
not count towards the overall score at
the end
so secondly we will test
a set of eight general competencies and
we do so
uh through two tests both of these tests
are to be conducted in english
there is an oral presentation to be done
which will test four competencies
and there is a situational competency
based interview during which we test
four more competencies you see though
in this slide here
the whole test or both of these tests
are to be conducted in english
again you need a combined pass mark at
least 40 out of 80.
currently um or i mean the the score you
get here
will count towards the end okay so it is
important to score well on each of these
competencies um that you are tested in
secondly uh we test a set of field
related competencies
again through two different tests
there's an interview and there's a
written test where we test
your competencies and knowledge uh in
the field
you need at least 25 out of 50 both
times and again your score here does
count towards the overall score
the best ones scoring end up on the list
of successful candidates and those are
the ones that will be recruited by this
dg deficit as said in the beginning you
see the numbers of laureates requested
here so we need 32 successful candidates
in the 87
grade for defense 16 for 89 and so on so
in total we're looking to recruit 100
people so it's quite a big competition
actually
so
i invite you to
apply
please do read the notice of competition
carefully this is the legal document
containing all information on the duties
the eligibility criteria the different
steps of the competition in detail
you'll find most of the of your answers
of any question you might have in this
notice of competition so do read
carefully
if you would have more questions to this
competition you can always reach out to
us
via our web form on the website
and we can then come back to you with
any answer
that's it for now good luck to this
competition and see you around next time
bye